c'est noël
il faut fêter ça qu'ils disaient
une petite soirée pour le personnel
boire quelques verres décompresser un
peu pas de folie joyeux noël jérémy
sacrée soirée
voici un exemple de plateau de fromages
pour notre petite fête de ce soir pardon
vous avez prévu une petite fête ce soir
hors de question je regrette hockey chez
annulés et du comment tu crois peut-être
que je t'ai pas vu non mais j'ai comme
tu veux si tu veux qu'on annule on a lu
je ne plaisante pas je veux que m arrête
de faire ça
et
si vous avez l'intention d'avoir des
relations sexuelles veuillez s'il vous
plaît les faire en dehors des locaux de
la société fait ça sur le parking dakota
shirt bleu sur le parti de pasqua
oh pardon
père noël tu vas t'éclater je crois
qu'il s'est totalement soirée